يختنق صوتها تحاول عبثا ان تمنع دموع ام
ممتنه بعوده ابنها من الاسر
في بيتهم في تسكلوسه في ولايه الاباما
ذهبنا لنسمع من هذه العائله كيف نجحت
الوساطه السعوديه بتعليمات من ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان باطلاق سراح اليكس
دروكي من سجن روسي بعد اعتقاله لمده اربعه
اشهر اليكس تطوع للقتال في صفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه الى ان وقع بالاسر من قبل
الجنود الروس الذين قاموا بتعذيبه وترك
مصيره معلقا بين الحياه والموت
ان اتمكن من تجاوز هذا دون ان ابكي انا
ممتنه جدا لتدخل ولي العهد ومساعدته اعتقد
حقا ان اليكس لن يكون هنا اليوم لو لم يكن
ولي العهد على استعداد تام للمساعده ساكون
مديونه دائما للسعوديه وللشعب ولولي العهد
على وجه الخصوص اليكس الذي يتعافى بعد
الاسر لا يزال يعاني مختلف في الاعصاب
ومتاعب صحيه ويخضع لمراقبه طبيه يحاول ان
ينحت بالخشب ليمرن اصابعه المعطوبه لكنه
يعتبر نفسه محظوظا كونه واحدا من عشر اسرع
حرب تم اطلاق سراحهم بواسطه سعوديه
انتظرنا في المطار ثم اخذونا اخيرا الى
الترام وراينا هناك على المدرسه طائره
سعوديه كبيره وقلنا حسنا هذا ليس حقيقيا
لن يتم وضعنا فيها ثم كنت اتساءل ما هي
تلك الطائره هناك ثم وضعنا فيها وبدا
الموظفون السعوديون في الواقع يتحدثون
الينا ويشرحون ما يجري ويقولون اننا في
امان وانه سوف يطلق صراحنا وانهم سوف
يعتنون بنا لم يكن الامر حقيقيا حتى هبطنا
في الرياض
سباق مع الزمن من اسره اليكس في محاوله
لاطلاق سراحه ترويها خالته ديانه حيث قامت
بالاتصال مع السينات
ومع وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لكن الافراج
عنه جاء من جهه لم تتوقعها
لم نكن متاكدين بالضبط من الجهه البسيطه
المساعده ثم عندما علمنا انها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كان الامر منطقيا بالطبع
لكننا لا زلنا لا نعرف بالضبط كيف حدث ذلك
لا نعرف كيف بدا الامر وكم من الوقت
استغرقت العمليه لاننا كنا نوعا ما في
الظلام اخبرتنا وزاره الخارجيه ان امورا
كانت تحدث لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من اخبارنا
بتفاصيلها
لا شيء يضاهي عوده ابن سالما من حرب بعيده
لكن لدى اسره الدروكي امنيه وحيده وهي شكر
السعوديه على منح ابنها فرصه ثانيه في
الحياه ناديه البلبيسي العربيه تسكلوسه من
ولايه الاباما